so what is the line between that  biological predisposition and addiction  i think you know as a man  you would know you would know whether  you're doing something  for whatever reason you're doing it yeah  and sometimes you would like i don't  even know you know  everyone's been there you've done it  like what happened why did i do that why  did i even have sex with that girl do  you know what i mean like you have that  feeling and so when you continuously  have that feeling i think that's when  you know that you're just doing it yeah  if it's against your better judgment and  you're like i know i shouldn't have done  that man that's why i find yours so  interesting because if you think of any  other walk of life or any other animal  or whatever you want to call it  they'll do it and then there's a long  interval in between it's not like  habitual like yeah  the women being like come on i'm in heat  yeah yeah